hey my name is weighty and he's a
telephone so call him maybe I am hidden
wasn't that a lady Gaga song - I don't
think that was who it was or call me on
my telephone go to voicemail I always
pick you up or text you back I hear so
much chaos what's happening no are you
just trying to give me away the crevices
the crevices oh god the way it spurts
blood he was a cop shut up I really wish
I couldn't eat wait a minute he might be
a filing cabinet why would you think
that mess
[Laughter]
those stupid things are so glitchy wait
a minute something right here I swear to
god these filing cabinets are messed up
what see whoever is messing with the
desk in the chairs right to be clear
mark I was one of those chairs you were
touching earlier are you kidding me no I
can't believe it in spot man
Oh what are you still a chair he's
nothing oh come on know what I still be
a chair the chair wait somebody in the
room with you right now huh
no wait Bob are you so good at this
where is you everything is so
disorganized everywhere sorry I'm sorry
I have no clue Bob do you see any of us
I see someone right now messing with
those boxes down that hallway as you
wait okay okay did you hear me wait
making sound no I I can make a sound
where I am right now I didn't hear
anything
I saw you bounce I was so much stuff
that round that was awesome that was
amazing we had no idea I said because I
kept just switching and chasing and
twitching and chasing and blah blah blah
oh oh no oh no oh no no no wait how they
help you what tell me wait like a chair
stuck under a desk I'm not seeing Bob
yet I hear Bob I don't see him how do
you hear me but not hey no how is that
possible you answer me that
how am that I see a lot of bullet holes
were you shooting it something already
ball shoot everywhere that's my strategy
Oh keep it up keep bullet holes yeah I
saw a lot of Boyles douchebags Oh Bobby
you are so high I saw you
you're so
save yourself
for the conference
[Laughter]
oh no you used up your blood everywhere
damn it all right ready Bob rocks and
I've watched you kill mark he was a
filing cabinet alone away mark I became
the smallest thing yet Oh Oh what is it
tell me tell me Bob where are you
I'll come see you spawn where where
we--where
I don't I lost him whoa oh my god what
we're playing on which way is he going
come off I think he went up the stairs
into the offices no I was been here I'm
standing here you could look up the
prob this is the best problem no Zen
with the snow it's not even Gopal
what's she doing down in that corner dad
in the corner of that outside garage
area who says that mark oh I saw you
under there but it was so hard to see
you I had to be in a far angle oh that
was the worst that was fun I should have
made it last longer
definitely coulda if you just got
outside the snow I never would have seen
you yeah
I didn't know you could become something
that small that was kind of just an
accident
very quiet mark where are you hiding I
am that was a very good voice there Bob
that was my impression of you
mark where are you hiding sketch-comedy
it was the Batman Perry you didn't you
never seen that no other college you
through that window it was a college
humor one is so funny like it's just
like Batman trying a bunch of trying to
find his voice while he's getting that
guy while he's hanging upside down in
Batman Begins hazley is that really
really your voice I guess through a
bunch of it I can't do you know what Wow
would you just die what's going on
honesty what's going on oh I hear
gunshots where are they what's that wait
where did you die tell me you know L
upstairs what does that mean I know when
you laugh at me like I do is stop and
you'll chase me like a [ __ ]
long I run around and I'm hunting it's
always like a ghost no uh no did you use
your grenade already no I thought I
heard an explosion if you did it was it
for me you didn't hear anything
well well well did your prop explode
yeah I turned into a grenade your
character has like dead white eyes it
also turn the corner just standing with
your arms out good god it turns out
we're playing gmod horror maps too well
where you going mark I don't know what's
going on your glass where you are I'm
not alright wait I think I'm clear Oh Oh
God are you really that close to him yes
very startling like your footsteps
ooh
Oh Bob way to go whoa what was that was
it that was loud I hear she gunshots
where are you you bastard
Oh God How well do you know these Mads
not that well it was really awkward
you weren't straight I don't know if you
thought you were lined up oh yeah wait
sometimes you think you're straight and
then you're not you know I think you did
a thing there man I thought I had it
no I saw Marco flying through as a red
cup like in a million miles an hour
I just never know where Bob is and also
he appears Lucas oh you know where I
just randomly changed directions
sometimes I don't know it was in normal
people okay oh [ __ ]
Oh God oh yeah yeah okay well this is
what I've done now this is my choice
yeah yeah yeah yeah this [ __ ] am i you
uh closer are you mark a good idea to be
something really huge it turns out to be
the worst plan am i getting near to you
oh we're looking bad Wade oh wait we're
like a bad god damn wait are you still
in here Bob Bob why are you in here
where'd you go where'd you go
where are you he was right here there's
a box on top of this counter Oh God
dingus I just kept laughing cuz I
thought it was hilarious at you when I
started laughing the first time you
found it was in that room I couldn't
stop laughing why cuz you're stupid
[Music]
you tuuuu eyes